les salariés de la maison burtin ne
décolère pas ce jeudi ils étaient une
cinquantaine à participer à la grève
illimitée déclenchée la veille afin de
se faire entendre les grévistes se
rassemblent pour débattre de la durée
quotidienne de ce mouvement l'objectif
est clair ralentir la production de
champagne pour attirer l'attention de
leur pdg et obtenir une revalorisation
de 6 % de leur salaire gelé depuis
plusieurs années faut savoir que depuis
2007 dans cette entreprise qui a été
reprise par le groupe lanson bcc nous
n'avons jamais eu d'augmentation
voilà j'avais eu de prime sarkozy on n'a
jamais eu de prix macron on n'a jamais
rien eu au passage puis ce qu'on
travaillait pas assez on avait trois
quarts d'heure de pause qui était inclus
dans nos temps de travail on les a on
les a enlevées donc ça fait que on
travaille 160 plus de 170 ans deux de
plus à l'année tout ça sans être
rémunéré au milieu des grévistes le père
noël sonne la cloche pour inciter leurs
pdg a plus de générosité
j'ai rencontré la direction mardi
pour discuter suite au mécontentement
des salariés
parce que il voudrait avoir une
augmentation de salaire on nous a dit
non clairement nom restera figé là
dessus et monsieur le rhc permis de me
dire nous sommes pas le père noël on a
beau demander il reste fermé la
discussion
on peut jamais débattre de quelles que
soient nos demandes c'est non contacté
par rt france la direction du groupe n'a
pas souhaité faire de commentaire sur ce
mouvement social les salariés restent
déterminés et là sur d'autres
mobilisations sont à prévoir et ce tant
que leurs demandes demeurent sans
réponse